uh grace blakely i haven't seen you for
a while hey nice to be back welcome back
nice of you to stop gallivanting around
the world um what do you make of all
this
well i mean you know i think what we've
just heard the uh trust has appointed a
lot of key allies to um senior positions
out of basically fear that she's going
to be stabbed in the back tells you a
lot of what you need to know about this
government which is that she's come in
from a relatively weak position she
doesn't have the support of a lot of her
mps she doesn't have as strong support
among the conservative party membership
as we might have thought certainly the
beginning of the campaign the campaign
obviously had its own fair share of
fiascos and u-turns um and didn't leave
her
looking particularly prime ministerial
and now she's going into this massive
crisis you know and she has to basically
try and unite
two wings of the conservative party one
of which is kind of boris's populist um
you know what they're doing
and then the the right wing free market
near liberals here's the problem richard
i don't care about the infighting of the
bloody conservative party i want them to
focus on the people of this country it
all revolves that's my problem i'm fed
up with all this in fighting and to be
honest it all revolves around the energy
plan i produced a a an emergency energy
plan three weeks ago i know it's been
looked out in the heart of government if
she gets that right
this week she will get a big big boost
she will unite millions of households up
and down the country how can she do it
and
cut taxes very simply you put the you
put the onus on the uh the gas producers
the energy generators
not on us the taxpayer and the borrower
because otherwise you're literally
borrowing from us taxpayer to give it to
your producers i said you've got to
revert to the average 2021 price for the
wholesale price and you've got to say to
all the generators in the uk that's what
you're doing that's the price you get
i do not disagree with richard
actually i know this is crazy isn't it
wonderful it is it's it's brilliant
because it's very obvious what we're
seeing at the moment it looks like the
beginning of a plan from this trust
which is an energy price cap but it's
not an energy price cap because a cap
implies that you are um you know capping
the price at which producers can sell
and that involves them taking a hit
potentially with a small subsidy from
the state what she's really doing is
saying you guys keep all the profits you
carry on making all the extraordinary
profits you're making and we will um
basically pay you the difference between
what consumers are paying at this cap
level so it's corporate welfare
basically but the point is this isn't
for six months peers we're in a global
energy war that could last three five
seven years so you have to have a plan
that responds to that the problem that
charles has got is that none of the
plans she has for making britain less
energy dependent on other countries are
going to kick in before an election
exactly she's got a ticking clock to
violation i want to bring in douglas
murray across the pond there in new york
douglas looking from afar
what what do you make of this this trust
i don't think i can ever remember any
leader short of
after world war ii
inheriting a worse situation than this
do you have any confidence that liz
trusts is the woman to guide us to
to quieter waters to calmer waters
uh not very much i wish her well as i
think everybody
should uh the only person i can think of
who came into a worse position was
theresa theresa may after her very bad
call in the 2017 uh general election uh
um the problem that liz trust is getting
into is this as as your other guests
have just said um it's unlikely whatever
she does that the benefits of her
governance are going to be felt fast uh
everything to do with the energy crisis
everything to do with the costs of
living crisis
she's got basically two years uh uh to
solve these things and it seems very
unlikely she could do it in that time
and here's here's the bigger problem
here's as you well know
we're now 12 years in
to conservative governance in the uk 12
years
and to a great extent this feels to me
like the major years when you had that
third press of the conservative talent
and you had all of these crises and the
feeling that they couldn't get on top of
it i of course hope like everybody else
that liz trust can but the problem she
has is that you know
the question will keep being asked
particularly by the labour opposition
well who's been running the joint for
the last 12 years okay for five years
the conservative party had nick clegg
manacled to their leg a very unpleasant
situation for anyone to be in but after
those five years we have had seven years
of conservative
majority rule yeah and you know all of
these all of these questions that are
coming up are questions that could have
been answered before and you all and i
think we are gonna we're gonna start
hearing the same excuses from
conservative ministers as we've heard in
recent years they'll tell us that the
blob is the problem that the civil
service is the problem that the unions
are the problem and all sorts of other
things and they may be right on that but
the question will keep coming up or
who's been in charge i agree i mean let
me bring
grace back in on that because the other
problem they've got liz charles has got
she got the specter of boris johnson and
be lurking like this ugly shadow in the
background ready to pounce you know he
did a typical boris job this morning i
was watching it live he comes out
doesn't apologize for anything no
regrets all very buffoonery these are
all my greatest hits it's all been a
tremendous success and see you later and
then the sun came out i kind of shot on
this guy as he sauntered out of downing
street compared to poor old trust who
got poured on and you know he's a he's a
lucky general boris in many ways doesn't
he he then quoted uh some roman emperor
who famously went back to a farm and
plowed the fields what he didn't mention
was that emperor he then came back from
from the field he left his plan came
back to save the country he sounds like
trump when he speaks like this i know of
course i mean you know why do you think
he did this ridiculous farewell tour uh
going around saying look at all the
wonderful things i've done look at how
green i've made britain despite the fact
that if we had actually gone green we
wouldn't be dealing with the scale of
this energy crisis that we're dealing
with right now um he's obviously
planning on coming back you know he's
going to go away go on the speaking
circuit make millions make huge money
the book will make millions of money
while people in this country are
literally struggling to eat their homes
come back when he's dealt with all of
his offspring and given them as much
shamelessness with politicians can be
very successful donald trump boris
johnson they have no shame just focus on
the track record 12 years as douglas
said of tory leadership tory government
has left as you said a crisis of crisis
there are so many you can't name them
all you forget them i mean this is
incompetence it's negligence and it's
the british people the lowest paid the
least well-off yes who are going to
suffer the most yes and that's what i
really really resent it is actually the
legacy of a failed macroeconomic agenda
that liz trusts is saying that she's
basically going to revive she's saying
i'm the next thing which by the way her
fingerprints have been all over as a
member of successive government she's
been there ten years yeah so she's like
she's not squeaky clean coming in here
like nothing to do with me
it was you gov right i mean you know
what's she going to do tax cuts right
okay we've already got high levels
inequality thatcher did we can't afford
to well
it's a big i keep mentioning this
margaret thatcher when she came in and
inherited a very hard situation bad
economy she didn't cut taxes she put she
waited a few years she put them up to
scotland
settled down then rate of income tax was
80 percent let's let's be very close to
power and then she said you can't tax
your way out of a crisis you've got to
grow your way out of a crisis after the
second world war our national debt fell
from 150
uh down to about 50
very very quickly because of growth and
she's right on that because you've got
to catch up
they do if you cut taxes then you know
we would have astonishing
over taxes of the coalition government
they caught corporations for 17 years
we're in a race to the bottom
incorporation tax
actually as leaders from thatcher to
reagan and others have proven when the
economy is doing well and is stable and
you cut taxes you can get the growth but
how do you get the economy
stable low levels of inequality you need
investors i don't think you can do it
i don't think you can massively increase
borrowing by 100 billion and
cut taxes and expect the government
the government balance sheet is
absolutely fine as long as you cut taxes
you cut unnecessary regulation and you
go for growth what you don't do is
borrow to subsidize to give a hundred
billion quid to a bunch of already very
rich investors in operations
you